welcome to CBS this morning on another
historic day in Washington in just a few
hours House Democrats will unveil two
articles of impeachment against
President Trump
sources tell CBS News the inquiry led by
congressman Jerry Nadler and Adam Schiff
will accuse the president of abuse of
power and obstruction of Congress this
is happening one day after the House
Judiciary Committee met to review the
evidence under the Democrats timeline
mr. Trump could be formally charged next
week
yesterday the president once again
called the process a quote disgrace to
our country Nancy Cordes is on Capitol
Hill for us again Nancy good morning
what else do we know well democratic
sources tell CBS News that they have
decided to narrow the scope of
impeachment so that means likely no
bribery no obstruction of justice
instead they will be focusing on what
they say is his abuse of his position
and his decision to try to keep that
information from Congress the danger to
our democracy is clear and our duty is
clear less than a day after laying out
the evidence for lawmakers president
Trump's conduct sought to undermine our
free and fair elections Democrats will
reveal their articles of impeachment
focusing on what they say was the
president's abuse of his office for
personal gain who ordered his own chief
of staff Mick Mulvaney to withhold
critical military assistance for Ukraine
President Trump who personally asked
President zalenski to investigate his
political rival Joe Biden President
Trump so as it relates to President
Trump is he an incidental player or a
central player in this scheme President
Trump is the central player in this
scheme as impeachment nears tensions are
rising we want shift in that chair not
you
Republicans accusing the majority of
steamrolling them you weren't elected by
anybody you're here giving this
testimony in place of the Chairman
Republicans insist the evidence is
inconclusive at best the impeachment
inquiry record is riddled with hearsay
presumptions and speculation Democrats
say the
it's true there's a lot of direct
evidence and a lot of the evidence that
they say is hearsay is actually not
hearsay speaker Pelosi said last night
she won't pressure any of her members to
vote to impeach on an issue like this
they don't count the votes people will
just do what they do there are a couple
of steps before we get to that full
House vote the speaker was talking about
after the articles of impeachment are
laid out this morning the House
Judiciary Committee will have to debate
on and vote on those articles that vote
will likely happen this Thursday if the
articles are approved in committee they
would then go to that full House vote
which could happen early next week that
would set the stage for a trial in the
Senate early next year
Toni Nancy thank you very much and CBS
News will bring you the announcement of
the articles of impeachment in a special
report we expected to begin at 9:00 a.m.
Eastern 8:00 o'clock Central Time